ja heute geht es um unser kerngeschäft
an diesem tisch nämlich um das gespräch
und darum wie das gespräch gelingt und
deshalb bin ich sie heute gar nicht
lange zu texten sondern sage nur
herzlich willkommen und stelle ihnen
meine gäste vor
bei uns sind heute gefragt die mission
ist politikwissenschaftlerin und
einflussreiche journalistin und
aktivistin aus hamburg und bei unserem
tisch sitzt auch bernhard pörksen er ist
professor für medienwissenschaften an
der universität tübingen auch er mischt
sich mit seinen büchern und
zeitungsbeiträgen immer wieder in die
öffentliche debatte ein
schön sind sie da herzlich willkommen
schönheit kaugummis sie schreiben in
ihrem soeben oder von paar wochen
erschienenen buch sprache und sein dass
sie ganz oft eingeladen werden in
fernsehsendungen zum beispiel auf
intellektuelle putzfrau das heißt an
einem wirklich im gespräch ist man gar
nicht interessiert häufig werden den
öffentlichen talkshows bestimmte
fragestellungen gestellt die eigentlich
destruktiv sind die uns nicht wirklich
weiter bringen und dann werden personen
eingeladen die dann diese destruktiven
thesen dann ausführlich vorstellen und
gleichzeitig werden menschen wie ich
eingeladen die dann hinterher räumen
sollen die dann so basic human dies sind
sie im zahlen daten und fakten versuchen
dagegenzuhalten
und während die gesamte sendung über
eigentlich das thema bestimmen wie wir
über das thema sprechen und die art und
weise wie die sendung abläuft bestimmen
sind menschen wie ich damit beschäftigt
hinterher zu räumen und versuchen
irgendwie andere argumente einzubringen
und dieser schlagabtausch ist ein
inszenierter schlagabtausch das geht gar
nicht darum tatsächlich irgendwie weiter
zu kommen oder am ende der sendung das
gefühl zu haben man hat das problem dass
besser verstanden sondern es ist eine
inszenierung wo absolute wahrheiten
gegeneinander antreten und dann um die
absolute wahrheit kämpfen und die
position schon geklärt sind sie richtig
herr persson als was werden sie
eingeladen
das ist eine sehr viele harmlose rolle
talkshow macher nennen dass das beiboot
also das melancholische medien
analytiker der einige schwer
verständliche sätze von der seite aus
äußert ich hab sie nicht ausreichen
er wird jetzt nicht wieder aber manchmal
muss sie dann wieder nach oben ich nicht
aufgehört habe zu reden aber ganz
ernsthaft gesprochen ist natürlich im
punkt also warum spricht man miteinander
spricht man miteinander um zu verstehen
spricht man miteinander um bereits vor
festgelegte positionen auszutauschen und
in der tat also es ist auch mein
eindruck vieler der talkshows sind im
grunde genommen scripted reality formate
für intellektuelle
das heißt sie werden angerufen und sagen
die leute sagen meistens irgend ein
armer praktikant oder eine praktikantin
vertreten sie wirklich diese harte
position und vor allem würden sie das
dann auch bei uns so sagen und dann
merken sie okay für welche rolle werden
sie gebucht und in diese rolle werden
sie gewissermaßen hinein verkostet und
die müssen sie dann auch spielen
und das heißt es geht nicht um
erkenntnis sondern um spektakel und das
ist eigentlich eine ziemlich desolate
fertige gesprächssituation ich glaube
wenn wir recherchieren würden wir würden
nie den moment letzter satz nie den
moment finden an dem jemand sagt in
einer der großen talkshows stimmt sie
haben ja recht ich will noch mal
nachdenken vielleicht geben sich mehr
moment und ich sehe es anders und man
ist sozusagen in einem modus der
revision der eigenen position
jetzt ist natürlich diese scripted
reality etwas eben was man vielleicht
kennt von von den medien vom fernsehen
machen oder auch flächen serien aber ihr
punkt ist ja noch mal ein anderer sie
würden wahrscheinlich sagen ihr ganzes
leben ist ganz eine scripted reality sie
sind nämlich eine sogenannte benannte
nennen sie das in ihrem buch erzählen
sie mal was sie damit genau meinen ihrem
buch geht es auch darum wie bestimmte
menschen unserer gesellschaft primär als
vertreter einer kategorie wahrgenommen
werden also nicht als individuen die
ambiguität besitzen komplexität besitzen
facettenreichtum besitzen makel und
fehler und ecken kanten besitzen also
dinge die uns menschen zu menschen
machen sondern mit diese menschen werden
primär über eine kategorie wahrgenommen
alles was sie tun wird in relation zur
kategorie betrachtet und fehler der
kategorie werden auf sie übertragen also
beispielsweise der ostdeutsche die
schwarze frau und in meinem fall auch
eine benannte die muslimische frau und
eine szene beispielsweise im buch
wo ich versucht habe deutlich zu machen
mit welcher last bestimmte menschen in
unserer gesellschaft durch die welt
laufen ist wenn ich über eine rote ampel
laufen würde dann würde nicht ich kuba
gemischter über die ampel laufen sondern
der gesamte islam 1,9 milliarden
menschen würden mit mir gemeinsam die
verkehrsregeln missachten
und das ist natürlich zugespitzt
formuliert aber eigentlich um zu
transportieren welche last auf menschen
laste den individualität nicht
zugestanden wird
und interessant zugestanden wird ist
genau dieses dieser begriff dass sie
nämlich zeigen eigentlich ist es ein
privileg um ihr war das vorher so gar
nicht bewusst ambivalenzen haben zu
dürfen also nicht in einer rolle
eingesperrt zu sein sondern
unterschiedliche sein zu dürfen
empfinden sie das auch so abhetzen
dürfen sieben unterschiedliche sein
ja das ist dass sie das fragen weil das
professoren modell oder das rollenmodell
des professors relativ elastisch sie
können mit verwuschelten haaren
auftreten sie müssen kein gutes auto
fahren und sie werden trotzdem beim arzt
vorgehaltene vor gelassen und einfach
klar professorentitel zumindest es in
deutschland so ein extrem autoritäts
gläubiges land ich weiß nicht wie es
hier in der schweiz ist also wir sagen
in diesem rollenkonzept werden sie mit
privilegien bombardiert und können die
schmerzen einer
diskriminierungserfahrungen denn es ist
ja eine solche dieses weggesperrt werden
in ein klischee käfig das ist ja
ungeheuer schmerzhaft weil sie erleben
sie werden nicht gesehen sie waren nicht
wahrgenommen
sie sind im grunde genommen nicht
interessant sondern nur als der
stichwortgeber im vorgefertigten skript
und dieses diese erfahrung die mache ich
so nicht das muss ich tatsächlich so
sagen
und das interessante ist ja dass
menschen häufig deshalb also kategorien
sind wichtig wir brauchen sie um die
welt irgendwie zum bad zu nehmen
einzuordnen uns dadurch zu navigieren
was aber passiert ist das die art und
weise wie die über menschen sprechen und
wie vize kategorien kategorisieren zu
mit seinem absolut heitz glauben
stattfindet das heißt man glaubt man
hätte einen menschen abschließend
verstanden weil man diese person einer
korrekten kategorie zugeordnet hat unser
kann es im alltag sein dass sie von
menschen stehen und märkten diese
personen kann sie nicht sehen weil sie
primär in ihnen an
gefahrenquelle sehen oder weil sie ihm
primär eine person sehen die diesem oder
jenem kia zugehört und diese
entmenschlichung das ist eine
tatsächliche physische wahrnehmung und
ein physisches erleben weil sie dann vom
menschen stehen und merken dass die
augen so eine art schleier vor den augen
haben und nicht wirklich in die augen
schauen können und den menschen als
menschen wahrnehmen
ich habe versucht dazu ein beispiel zu
finden haben hier ihr facebook profil
angesehen
und da gibt es ja einmal jenseits davon
dass es einfach auf unglaubliche
beschimpfungen ihrer person gibt gibt es
einen post der auch sehr unschön ist
aber steht du bist doch ein fake man
kann nicht behaupten feministin zu sein
um die gerechte sprache fernen verwenden
und zur selben zeit eine kopf windel
tragen und möchte ich nicht über kopf in
ihn sprechen das ist ein extrem
diskriminieren da die familien der
ausdruck aber hier geht es ja genau um
diese schwierigkeit man darf nicht oder
kann nicht feministin sein und ein
kopftuch tragen währenddessen op termin
ist in bin oder nicht erst mal
interessiert dass wahrscheinlich kein
mensch aber vor allem würde man es mir
zugestehen man würde mir aber auch
zugestehen keine zu sein weil es nicht
von mir gibt an dem mann zu erkennen
meint ob ich für mich ist in wien oder
nicht das ist der punkt oder ja aber
eigentlich wenn wir uns ganz genau mit
der strömung architektursprache befassen
und die art und weise wie wir über
menschen sprechen dann sehen wir dass
die allermeisten menschen unserer
gesellschaft eigentlich nirgends der typ
gedrängt werden beispielsweise wenn man
über menschen sagt die powerfrau oder
dann sind halt eine powerfrau bestimmte
klischees gebunden ja also diese frauen
haben keine kinder oder wenn sie kinder
haben da sind sie rabenmütter also
eigentlich gibt es bei den allermeisten
menschen unserer gesellschaft grube
klischees und weil in der art und weise
wie wir über menschen sprechen
eigentlich auch eine perspektive noch
inne wohnt und wie er über mit
bestimmten augenmenschen betrachten und
das interessante ist wenn wir dann jetzt
heute auf die aktuellen diskurse schauen
und in den letzten drei vier jahren hat
das sehr viel die runde gemacht der
begriff der alte weiße mann und sobald
dieser name gefallen es gab es viele
aggressive gegenreaktion
das interessante ist dass folgendes
nämlich passiert in dem moment wird ein
alter weiß hermann
in der über seine kategorie wahrgenommen
also ihm werden auch individualität
komplexität ambiguität abgesprochen und
er muss sich in relation zu seiner
kategorie verhalten
deshalb kommt eine große aggression dann
bei dieser benennung daher und ich finde
es wichtig das zu beschreiben um
deutlich zu machen andere menschen
unserer gesellschaft leben ein leben
lang damit frage
doch wie nur ganz kurz ein haken ist
denn der alte weise man genauso
problematisch die zusagen die powerfrau
oder buslinien es sind eigentlich immer
diese stereotype gleichermaßen
problematisch natürlich sind bestimmtes
typisch viel stärker verankert in
unserer gesellschaft und dieses
stereotyp der alte weise man doch
vielleicht nur punktuell auf während
andere stereotypen permanent auftauchen
und ein entschieden sozusagen nicht
möglich ist aber prinzipiell ja und die
frage ist dann nicht zu sagen ja okay
jetzt sollen hier auch mal leiden um zu
spüren wie es ist eine frau zu sein ein
trans mann zu sein oder ein geflüchteter
zu sein sondern vielmehr die frage die
wir uns stellen müssen wie können wir
miteinander sprechen auf eine
respektvolle menschliche art und weise
so dass facettenreichtum allen
zugestanden wird
und ich würde interessieren warum kommt
denn zu diesen pauschalisierung die aso
zu nehmen und doch noch mal die frage
sie haben jetzt gesagt ja ist eigentlich
das gleiche weil egal welche stereotype
wir jetzt verwenden
aber es war ja doch so dass sehr viele
frauen sich zum beispiel gewehrt haben
gesagt haben wir wollen nicht mehr nur
aus frauen gesehen werden aber
genussvoll dass der typ des alten weißen
mannes verwenden also wieso kommst du
dieser stereotypisierung sind wirklich
alle gleichermaßen problematisch ja ich
glaube es ist die haltung wie unser
sprechen regiert die tatsächlich
problematisch ist vermutlich können wir
nicht ohne ein gewisses maß an
klischiert haid vermutlich können wir
nicht unendlich feinkörnig beobachten
vermutlich ist sozusagen eine soziale
mikroskopie die immer das individuum
feiert und nicht sagt die journalistin
oder die aktivistin oder der professor
vermutlich ist das nicht möglich das
problem dass basis rezepte so kränkend
ist ist die verallgemeinerung dass ein
merkmals ich nenne ihnen ein beispiel
das manchmal so
hat es in den 60er jahren gab es so
einen ersten protagonisten der sprawl
und spektakel shows im fernsehen job 1
hieß der und schob ein hat seine gäste
ganz anders als es hier ist ja sehr
gesittet und sehr freundlich und sehr
nett hat seine gäste immer beleidigt und
gekränkt und angepöbelt und worin hatte
ein holzbein mein baum portiert worden
hat dann holzmann kommt also frank zappa
in dieser sendung mit seinen langen
haaren dieser musiker und tobt einfängt
in dem üblichen aggression stone an hat
aber sie haben so lange haare sind sie
etwa eine frau und frank zappa sagt
schlagfertig wie er ist sie haben ein
holzbein sind sie etwa ein tisch und das
ist aus meiner sicht genau der
mechanismus der regiert man greift ein
einzelnes merkmal raus kopftuch
akademiker alt weiß was auch immer
und sagt dieses allgemeine dieses
einzelmerkmale steht schon für das ganze
und darin liegt die unverschämtheit
darin liegt die kränkung und deswegen
ist jedes pauschalurteil sozusagen von
einer ungerechtigkeit die unmittelbar
widerstand erzeugt und am ende des tages
wollen dann alle aufeinander ein weil
sie sich zu recht ungerecht behandelt
fühlen und sie wollen heute darüber
reden wie wir eben reden können statt
brüllen wie das gelingen kann und ich
möchte da mal kurz wie die szenerie
wechseln sie haben ja auch gerade ein
buch geschrieben was jetzt herauskommt
gemeinsam mit friedemann schulz von thun
die kunst des miteinander redens und sie
stellen da eine steile these auf wie ich
meine die sagen nämlich im grunde
genommen kann mir ganz viel lernen zur
wie wir zur entgiftung der öffentlichen
kommunikation beitragen können wir die
zurückfahren können indem wir private
konfliktsituationen studieren schauen
was passiert nach und etwas daraus
ziehen und wir schauen uns doch jetzt
mal so eine private situation an die
habe ich aus ihrem buch und ich versuche
die kurz nachzustellen kinder gucken
fern sie wissen sie dürfen 30 minuten
nach 30 minuten kommt der fahrt einen
raum und sagt so kinder 30 minuten sind
um
er schaltet jetzt mal schön den
fernseher aus und die kinder mal und
sagen es gerade so schön bitte bitte
noch ein bisschen und der vater sagt
nein regel ist regel da tritt die mutter
auf und sagt
machen sie doch nicht so kleinlich die
kleinen gucken gerade so schön fern
lasst sie doch noch nicht sagt er was
ich so kleinlich sein du lässt die an
kinder vor der glotze verdummen dann
wehrt sie sich und sagt wieso musst du
mich immer so niedermachen vor den
kindern das ist so eine eskalation
geschichte die wir alle glaube ich
leider kennen ziemlich typisch oder
absolut und sie sehen hier beide
wechseln werden sich maximal ab
friedemann schulz von thun bringt das
auf die polarisierung formel schlechthin
ich bin das ideal und du bist der
skandal die frau oder die mutter wirkt
flexibilität eigentlich ein wichtiger
wert der mann wirkt oder der vater wird
für regeltreue eigentlich auch ein
wichtiger wert und beide betrachten aber
gewissermaßen nur diesen einzelwert in
seiner negativen übertreibung also die
regeltreue wird zum total dogmatismus
stilisiert von seitens der mutter und
der vater tut so als sei diese
flexibilität und der endgültige abgrund
und der weg in die totale verblödung der
kinder die nun endlos fernsehen und
beides braucht das zusammen also
wahrheit entsteht zurzeit ein gutes
elternpaar wäre ein elternpaar das eine
mischung hinbekommt aus regeltreue und
flexibilität nur laissez-faire ist
vielleicht mist aber nur regeltreue ist
irgendwo eine kaserne und dahin zu
kommen also sozusagen den andern anders
zu sehen und in dem was man ablehnt
einen positiven anteil zu erkennen das
wäre der erste schritt der erste weg auf
dem weg hin zu einer polarisierung der
verhältnisse und zu einem gespräch sie
haben in ihrem buch jahr ein zitat
vorangestellt eine sophie mystikers ich
muss das ganz kurz vorlesen rooney
er hat geschrieben jenseits von richtig
und falsch liegt ein ort dort treffen
wir uns ist dass dieses gemeinsame
wahrheit finden
das ist einerseits das aber auch dass
verlassen dieser inszenierten gespräche
wo es nicht um tatsächliche
wahrheitsfindung geht sondern wo
bestimmte antagonisten gegeneinander
antreten aufseher polarisierte position
reduziert werden und um eine
vorherrschaft kämpfen ein sinnloses
spieler saßen
man verlässt dieses feld und zweitens im
bewusstsein zu leben das nur die
vielfalt der perspektiven uns ermöglicht
überhaupt an die wahrheit näher zu
kommen
juni tisch berichtet sprach davon das
ist ein perspektiv bewusstsein braucht
und wenn wir auf das andere thema das
wir gerade besprochen haben über
kategorien uns der e-type sprechen oder
aber auch wenn wir über politische
gegenwärtige konflikte und die
austragung im öffentlichen raum sprechen
dann sehen wir wie ein eklatanter mangel
an perspektiv bewusstsein dazu führt
dass man glaubt die eigene perspektive
sei die einzig legitime und ware
dabei sind viele gleichzeitig war und
nur der wenn man mit einer gewissen
demut in diese diskussion herangeht mit
einem gewissen bewusstsein dafür dass
der eigene horizont nicht das ende der
welt markiert sondern nur den eigenen
horizont dann würde man in den
öffentlichen diskurs und denke ich ein
stück weiterkommen
zumindest anders einander zuhören und
dann auch diesen moment erleben von
einer stimme darüber wird ihn
nachgedacht also man kann ja eigentlich
sagen perspektiv bewusstsein die beiden
das paar spricht eigentlich so er sieht
die szene von hier sieht von hier
ob sie sehen nichts gemeinsames richtig
ist dass das problem dieses mangelnde
perspektive wussten also wenn wir noch
mal über diese szene sprechen die man ja
nicht so gesagt ja genau das ist das
problem man muss gemeinsam wahrheit
finden warum kommst zu diesen konflikten
offenbar wollen die keine wahrheit
gemeinsam finden oder was ist denn das
problem aber das problem ist natürlich
wenn wir so einen fiktiven dialog jetzt
betrachten ist die sofort abwertung der
anderen seite das ist das escalation
smeton schlechthin also ein gutes
gespräch beginnt mit einem minimum an
wertschätzungen das nicht da ist kann
der kommunikative brückenbau überhaupt
nicht gelegen also die selbsterhöhung
bei gleichzeitiger diffamierung des
anderen ist ein absolut sicheres rezept
um ein gespräch scheitern zu lassen und
trotzdem und da bin ich ein bisschen
andere auffassung müssen wir natürlich
auch in der gegenwärtigen situation in
der ein amerikanischer präsident acht
bis zehn lügen das ist noch das minimum
das die washington post pro tag
registriert absondert müssen wir
natürlich auch eine form finden für den
wahrheitsgehalt
also ich wäre nicht einverstanden
gewissermaßen alles in eine vielzahl von
perspektiven aufzulösen sondern wir
müssen eine haltung finden die das
bestehen auf der eigenen wahrheit
ermöglicht aber doch ausreichend
respektvoll ist gegenüber dem anderen
weil sonst kommen wir in die gefahr aus
meiner sicht dass wir die fülle der
perspektiven feiern und am schluss uns
gewissermaßen unterhang unterhaken mit
den klimawandel leugnen oder den klassen
post modernen spielern die in einer aus
meiner sicht völlig verqueren euphorie
nur die fülle feiern also die stimme ich
zu
und zwar geht dieses öffentliche denken
und das zögern und zweifeln dass sich
selbst hinterfragen das bewusstsein für
die eigene perspektive nur dann wenn
alle mit dem bewusstsein an den tisch
vertreten und selbstverständlich der
rahmen so eingesetzt ist das
menschenfeindlichkeit wenn gewalt wenn
all diese dinge die unser miteinander in
seinen grundfesten ausmachen nicht
geduldet werden also ich finde es ist
sehr wichtig und das ist ja auch ein
problem unseres öffentlichen diskurses
das alles selbst irrelevante sste
aussagen und plötzlich zu themen erhoben
werden und geadelt werden die von allen
diskutiert werden müssen beispielsweise
wenn alexander gauland über jerome
boateng die fußball-nationalspieler sagt
die leute würden nicht zum nachbarn
haben wollen woraufhin eine debatte
darüber entbrannt ob schwarze menschen
gute nachbarn sein können oder eine
andere frage wäre wenn jemand behaupten
würde die erde ist eine scheibe
würden wir dann alle anfangen darüber zu
diskutieren ob das denn nun soll ist und
letzter satz dazu deshalb ist es sehr
wichtig dass wir den rahmen dass wir uns
sehr über den rahmen auch unterhalten
und ihn nach sätzen
es gibt einen sehr schönen satz von dem
afro amerikanischen schriftsteller
robert jones junior der sagt silvia
anlass das problem entsteht im mai
abbrechen und der isle of man ist also
wir können unterschiedlicher meinung
sein und trotzdem einander lieben bis zu
dem punkt wo unsere nicht über einen
kunst darin begründet ist dass mir meine
menschlichkeit abgesprochen sind mein
recht diese gemeinsame wertschätzung aus
ausgangspunkte oder von dem sie
gesprochen haben sie erwähnen
buch auch daniel binswangen wir einen
schweizer journalisten der bei der
republik tätig ist
und der sagt ja es gibt eine seltsame
verzierung der gesprächsbereitschaft in
unserer gesellschaft fast schon
ja und ich stimme ihm zu es gibt ja jede
menge projekte die ihr zu tun als sei es
nur notwendig dass man möglichst viel
unterschiedlich denken dann einen tisch
bekommt das kann aber auch bedeuten dass
sich diese unterschiedlich denken dann
anschauen und dem gespräch erkennen dass
ihre unterschiede maximal sind und am
ende des tages aufeinander ein brüllen
also das gespräch ist kein allheilmittel
aber es ist ein wichtiger weg um
überhaupt eine brücke zu bauen um
andersdenkende zu verstehen und für mich
ist es ein ganz entscheidendes schluss
gewesen
schutz von toni schwierig so eine art
drei schritt der annäherung vor
verstehen muss man den anderen immer
dass es unbedingt geboten was sagt er
überhaupt verständnis haben ist ganz
gewiss sinnvoll kann man seine motive
seine empfindlichkeiten auch seine
schmerzen nachvollziehen aber ist man
einverstanden
das ist die schlüsselfrage vielleicht
überhaupt nicht und hier geht es darum
in einer zeit in der wir wie nie zuvor
in der medien und kommunikations
geschichte konfrontiert sind mit
andersdenkenden ansichten mit
unterschiedlichkeit mit immer neuen
großen und kleinen ideologien geht es
aus meiner sicht darum so eine zukunfts
tugend der respektvollen konfrontation
zu trainieren so wie sie das vorhin auch
gesagt haben wir sind vielleicht nicht
einer meinung aber wir können auf eine
ausreichend respektvolle weise streiten
und eine harmonie höherer ordnung
erleben die darin besteht dass die
unterschiede bestehen bleiben und dass
diese unterschiede in ordnung sind ohne
die überwältigung fantasie ohne das
gespräch in eine begradigung gespräch
und in eine unterwerfung situation zu
verwandeln
ich denke mir wir drei sind nun zwar
komplett einig und trotzdem habe ich
natürlich sofort die frage ich aber was
ist mit denjenigen die eben brüllen
wollen oder denjenigen die schon glauben
sie reden und ich empfinde sie aus
brüllende sie hat mit diesem begriff
intellektuelle putzfrau es haben sich
etwas ganz wichtiges wir sollten
aufpassen dass wir nicht sozusagen die
diskurs macht abgeben die anderen setzen
die themen und wir wissen immer
hinterher sondern dir
müssten auch so diejenigen die glauben
sie hätten konstruktives beizutragen
müssen auch die gespräche agenda setzen
können darf ich dazu ein halt sagen weil
aus meiner sicht ist es genau der punkt
wir haben ja eine enorme dominanz von
den rändern her die lauten die hassenden
die wütenden die pöbler bestimmendes
kommunikationsklima in einer massiven
weise schüchtern andere menschen ein
vertreiben sie aus der öffentlichkeit
und in dieser gesellschaftlichen
situation ist die gesellschaftliche
mitte oder gefordert wie nie die muss
die arena wieder betreten die muss
versuchen das kommunikationsklima zu
drehen und die muss die hater und köbler
als die kleine hässliche minderheit
vorstellen die sie faktisch sind denn
wir haben wir jede menge untersuchungen
die zeigen in welcher wie die
zahlenverhältnisse sind wie klein die
minderheit derjenigen ist die mit
maximalem möbel mit maximaler übel lust
und mit maximal und hass auf kommentare
5 prozent aller kam es zu 50 prozent
aller hass kommentare verantwortlich
aber wie kommen wir denn konkret weiter
also ich würde sagen dass diese probleme
auch zum teil symptome sind ja faktor
wenn wir uns die was für menschen wollen
wir unsere gesellschaft sein also wohin
treiben wir menschen welches verhalten
belohnen wir haben wir belohnt verhalten
wo menschen so tun als hätten sie alles
schon gesehen als wüssten sie schon
alles nicht neugier nicht wachstum nicht
fehlbarkeit nicht qualität nicht das
bewusstsein für die eigene unwissenheit
belohnen wir sondern wir belohnen
menschen die so tun als sei alles eine
klare antwort und sie müssten sie jetzt
nur noch vor kamera postulieren ist das
eine
ob nun unserem schulsystem ob das nun in
unserer öffentlichkeit oder kultur
stattfindet über als sieht sich das
durch der zweite faktor ist empörung ist
ein wichtiger politischer impuls und ein
wichtiges politisches werkzeug wenn wir
offline in einem raum wenden beispiel
wir sind in einem restaurant und es
kommt ein mann herein der fängt an zu
pöbeln und herumzuschreien gegenüber
einer person man würde sich dazwischen
stellen würde sagen mehr so geht das
nicht oder man würde zumindest die
augenbrauen hochziehen oder irgendwie
den kopf stecken weil das weggucken ist
ja auch nicht so richtig das heißt man
würde die
der person signalisieren so ein
verhalten nicht erwünscht irgendwann
würde sich wahrscheinlich das restaurant
management dazwischen schalten und die
person würde des restaurants verwiesen
werden oder aber würde sich
entschuldigen online passiert folgendes
im digitalen raum fängt die person an zu
pöbeln und mit jedem pöbeln sammelt die
person mehr augen auf sich mehr
aufmerksamkeit auf sich und jede
provokation ihre beleidigung jede neue
bodenlosigkeit führt dazu dass die
personen noch mehr aufmerksamkeit auf
sich konzentriert und aufmerksamkeit
stellen wir gleich mit relevanz und am
ende haben wir in unserer öffentlichkeit
nun plötzlich personen die über
provokation und pöbeln und
bodenlosigkeit sich relevanz erarbeitet
haben und bestimmen den öffentlichen
raum und das sind diejenigen die laut
sind und alle anderen wie sie
beschrieben haben
wir treten in den hintergrund wir wollen
ja was lernen über die therapie dieser
gesprächssituation und das war ja jetzt
auch noch mal viele analyse und die ist
ja ganz wichtig weil wenn man nicht
richtig analysiert muss man ja auch
nicht therapieren das wissen wir alle
aber ich würde trotzdem gerne fragen wie
kommen wir denn weiter und der ansatz
dieses buches ist sehr verführerisch
nämlich zu sagen lasst uns über diese
situation sprechen eine möglichkeit wäre
ja so ein bisschen
populärwissenschaftlich oder problem
psychologisch zu sagen na ja viele
konflikte kommen ja dadurch zustande
dass die personen selbst nicht gefestigt
sind dass sie sich selbst nicht mögen
zum beispiel also wenn man sich selbst
nicht schätzt wann ist man gar nicht in
der lage wertschätzung für andere zu
zeigen also möglicherweise fühlen die
personen sich gar nicht richtig
anerkannt und beginnen deswegen zu
pauschalisieren sich zu diffamieren und
so weiter sie ist das die richtige
analyse und was machen wir damit für den
öffentlichen diskurs was können wir
daraus lernen da ich will vielleicht
noch mal einen schritt zurücktreten wir
haben ja ganz viele wunderbare modelle
auf der ebene des individuums aus der
psychologie wie kriegt man verbiesterte
ehepaare dazu sich wieder mit empathie
zu betrachten wie kann man einen
einzelnen coachen der sich in seiner
arbeitssituation in furchtbarer weise
unter druck fühlt und wir ringen doch im
grunde genommen um die frage wie kann
unter den gegenwärtigen medien
bedingungen eine neue aufklärung
und der gedanke dieses buches ist es wir
bringen zwei felder zusammen auf der
einen seite die medienanalyse das
interesse am spektakel
der hype die neuen anreizsysteme in
richtung von emotionalität und
überhitzung auf der einen seite die
medienanalyse und auf der anderen seite
die kommunikationspsychologie diese
beiden perspektiven versuchen wir auf
dem weg zu einer anderen aufklärung und
auf dem weg zu einem anderen miteinander
reden zustande zu bringen sie fragen zu
recht wie kann das konkret gehen
ein punkt ist wertschätzung eine andere
ein abschied von einem dogmatischen
wahrheit' begriff eine ein interesse an
der nyse 1 überhaupt sich zeit nehmen
für das gespräch wir wissen aus den
entsprechenden forschung wenn das handy
permanent auf dem tisch liegt und
aufleuchtet ganz simpler hinweis dann
kann eine bestimmte gesprächs tiefe gar
nicht im c entstehen weil die
unterbrechung und ablenkungs drohung so
groß ist aber im kern geht es darum
gewissermaßen auch zu zeigen wie schön
ein dialog ist ein dialog ist
gewissermaßen ein tanz des denkens sie
können ja nicht andere bevormunden sie
können nicht den weg eines paternalismus
gehen das sind alles für eine demokratie
völlig unwürdige vorschläge aber die
schönheit eines dialoges vorzuführen und
zu zeigen das ist schon vielleicht eine
ästhetische verfügung die den ein oder
anderen der nur laut sein will womöglich
überzeugt oder inspiriert ich würde
einen punkt nach ergänzten knüpft
wahrscheinlich jetzt an den allerletzten
punkt tatsächlich an wie führt man das
vor und ich würde sagen dass sie im
öffentlichen raum einen großen mangel an
räumen haben den öffentliches denken
passieren kann wo menschen performativ
vorleben wie an dialog funktioniert und
dieser mangel des zweifels des zögerns
das nachdenken des innehaltens ist
natürlich auch eine negative
vorbildfunktion für die gesamte
gesellschaft und ich denke das es
braucht jetzt mit mehr vermehrt
medienformate öffentliche formate die
für ein großes publikum zugänglich sind
aufgrund mindestens eines grundes
nämlich wenn die zivilgesellschaft nicht
an öffentlichen denkprozessen teilhaben
kann
wenn immer nur so getan wird als gäbe es
fünf verschiedene oder sechs
verschiedene antworten auf eine große
frage
jetzt muss man schauen wer es
das kurs besser oder wer gewinnt oder
was tut man sich jetzt aus dann führt
das dazu dass wir stagnieren
dabei liegen die antworten häufig in der
kombination oder dem es gar nicht auf
dem tisch liegt und damit wir dahin
kommen braucht es diese formate und das
zweite ist ein anderes bewusstsein für
den umgang mit fehlern in diesen
öffentlichen formaten also der grund
weshalb wir nicht öffentlich denken ist
ja auch weil wir dafür geschafft werden
werden wir ein fehler machen wenn wir
uns an eine falsche quelle beziehen oder
etwas sagen was eigentlich verpönt ist
oder nicht wussten dass es derart
gesellschaftlich nicht toleriert wird
das heißt die angst vor fehlern führt
dazu dass wir uns nicht trauen
unausgegorene gedanken auszusprechen die
aber natürlich wichtig sind und der
quantenphysik untersucht damit david
bogen beschreibt das fehler ein großer
gewinn sind für einen diskurs er sagt
wenn ein fehler gemacht wird in einem
dialog dann gewinn alle weil über einen
fehler
erlangen die anerkenntnis gmünder nur so
kommen wir weiter und punkten halt macht
sich doch eine ganz brutale
schlussfolgerung anschließend an das
suggerieren zeit ist aber noch nicht was
folgerichtig doch nicht normal ich habe
ganz hohen respekt vor dem journalismus
ich habe selbst mal journalismus gelernt
in einem früheren leben aber im grunde
genommen das was sie sagen führt zu dem
gedanken gebrauchen einen anderen
journalismus journalismus ist von einem
entsetzlichen negativ ist muss er hat
ein anreizsystem in richtung des
abgrunds und das katastrophische der
journalismus ist fasziniert von dem
gedanken dass er seine unabhängigkeit
zeigt über die skandalisierung von mini
fehlern der journalismus ist fasziniert
von der idee dass alles und jedes was
irgendwie ein hauch von empörung und wut
verspricht ein relevantes thema sein
muss ich meine das ganz ernsthaft ich
denke im moment intensiv darüber nach
brauche wenig in einer zeit in der es
menschheits herausforderung wie den
klimawandel gibt ein völlig anderes
relevanz konzept das gegenwärtige
journalismus als wenn wir jetzt hier
schon mal miteinander denken und sagen
wir gehen jetzt ins offene das hat
nichts mit den büchern zu tun
dann würde ich sagen das ist eigentlich
das thema kann der journalismus sich so
ändern kann er seine ganzen blödsinnigen
frames ab
greifen und endlich seriöse relevanz
konzepte verfolgen ja oder nein das ist
für mich die schlüsselfrage weil er
bestimmt den öffentlichen raum wobei sie
in einem anderen buch noch die
geschrieben haben auch dafür plädieren
für eine redaktionelle gesellschaft also
sie sagen im grunde genommen jeder von
uns muss irgend in einer art und weise
journalist journalistin werden oder
zumindest eine medienkompetenz
mitbringen
und ich möchte das jetzt nicht noch
lange vertiefen aber was ich ja zeigt
diese these von ihnen ist es gibt
natürlich nicht einfach den journalismus
sondern es gibt immer auch die
rezipienten und rezipient und das schon
alles muss also leser und leserinnen
hörer und hörerinnen ein publikum
diejenigen die diese medien konsumieren
die diese medien weiter treiben und wir
alle sind medienschaffende zb in den
sozialen medien und wirklich hatte ich
immer das spielen auf den journalismus
finde ich auch jüngsten einseitig weil
es gibt auch alle die anderen wir alle
sind aber wir brauchen trotzdem
vorbilder wir brauchen vorbilder und sie
haben recht es ist ein
ungerechtfertigtes pauschale urteil über
den journalismus dass ich sofort
angreifen würde wenn ich selbst hätte ja
dann ist leider mal in ordnung aber
trotzdem ganz ernsthaft es gibt eine
tendenz
und die tendenz des journalismus passt
nicht mehr in unsere zeit das wäre meine
these in der ohnehin alle sich permanent
entführen und wären wir die relevanz
fragen neu sortieren müssen
ich würde sogar weitergehen ich würde
sagen dass wir grundlegend unsere
gesellschaft ein problem haben mit
umgang mit verantwortung macht die
allermeisten menschen die macht besitzen
müssen eigentlich wenn sie diese macht
also erstens sich dessen bewusst werden
dass die macht besitzen zweiter mit den
folgen dessen also mit dem
verantwortungsbewusstsein ein umgang
lernen und wir erleben dass er bei
firmen ja so wenn eine firma eine fabrik
flaschen herstellt und wasser verkauft
dann ist sie nicht verantwortlich für
die plastikflaschen die dann durch die
welt schwimmen
wir ziehen so zu sagen diejenigen die
dinge in die welt setzen nicht gänzlich
zur verantwortung für das was sie tun
ähnlich in der medienlandschaft wo wir
denn redaktionen dann bestimmte themen
zu relevanten themen erheben und breites
gut in die eigentlichen menschlichen
sind die eigentlich zum teil
verfassungsfest
endlich sind die eigentlich jeglichen
moralischen idealen widersprechen die
wir in einer demokratie in einer
pluralen demokratie haben weil dann
häufig das argument kommt wir bilden ja
nur ab was ist und erster damit haben
sie sich beschäftigt darüber wurde auch
schon viel gesprochen ist wie verzerrt
diese meinungsvielfalt in den digitalen
medien ist eine und das zweite ist
natürlich eine kernaufgabe und
kernkompetenz von medienschaffenden zu
bestimmen was ist relevant und und diese
aufgabe wird nicht ausreichend
tatsächlich nachgekommen und ich würde
auch sagen dass ein mangelndes
verantwortungsbewusstsein besteht und
das aber wiederum würde ich nicht
abladen wollen oft nur medienschaffende
sondern insgesamt als gesellschaft dass
wir nicht eine kultur pflegen des gegen
sich selbst zur verantwortung ziehen und
zwar nicht um dann und dieser macht und
last zusammenzubrechen sondern der
lösung daraus zu entwickeln
eigentlich wollten wir ja darüber
sprechen wie das gespräch gelingt und
jetzt sind sie eigentlich dauernd beim
misslingen und ich hab nur mal
dazwischen fest ich mache und
zwischenfazit
also wir haben fest gehabt ein gespräch
gelingt wenn es ein minimum gibt an
wertschätzung wenn man bereit ist zu
zögern wenn man der ansicht ist wahrheit
entsteht gemeinsam also ich hab sie
nicht gepachtet sondern es braucht diese
viel perspektive kite ich glaube das
waren so unendlich hoher see und ein
klarer rahmen
was heißt es also dann klappe rahmen
wäre beispielsweise alles was
verfassungsfeindlich ist alles was
menschen ihr dasein ihre existenz
abspricht diese dinge müsste man als
rahmenbedingungen festlegen und dann
kann man also ich kann nicht öffentlich
ins denken geraten mit einem menschen
der faschistisches gedankengut in einer
familie könnte man sagen darf auch keine
abhängigkeitsverhältnisse geben oder
also diese eltern personen sind gleich
gestellt zum beispiel dass man dürfte
zum beispiel in diesem fall nicht
darüber diskutieren ob dieses kind
sozusagen der familie verstoßen oder mit
mit diesem kind darüber zu diskutieren
ist verstoßen
es würde mich aber interessieren es gibt
ja schon situationen wo wir das gespräch
abbrechen und sie haben beide gesagt es
gibt auch ein
der gesprächsbereitschaft wenn nämlich
diese dinge nicht gegeben sind dann
wollen leute eben brüllen und nicht
reden
ein beispiel ist mir bei den sinn
gekommen ich möchte gerne mit ihnen
darüber sprechen da hat jemand das
gespräch abgebrochen
aus einem ganz anderen grund und zwar
ist es das beispiel der journalistin
rené j die ein buch darüber geschrieben
hat warum ich nicht länger mit weißem
über hautfarbe spreche und sie hat
gesagt ihr menschen da draußen die weiß
seit ihr seid so farbenblind ihr könnt
gar nicht erkennen was es heißt schwarz
zu sein dunkelhäutig zu sein eine andere
hautfarbe zu haben ich würde hier gerne
ganz kurz zu hören
ungefähr vor dreieinhalb jahren schrieb
ich einen post auf meinem blog mit dem
titel warum ich nicht mehr mit weißem
über rasse rede
ich schrieb ihn an einem punkt extremer
frustration und verzweiflung nachdem ich
einige jahre lang versucht hatte mit
weißem über rasse zu sprechen
es führte einfach zu nichts
ich bin nur ständig gegen eine wand
gerannt ich kam nicht weiter und ich war
emotional erschöpft
ich befand mich in feministischen
kreisen in progressiven kreisen bei
menschen die behaupten wirklich
progressiv zu denken
aber als ich versuchte mit ihnen über
rasse und rassismus zu sprechen war es
wie eine schwelle die man nicht
übertreten darf ich durfte nicht darüber
reden
ich wurde nun als der echte rassist
bezeichnet ich brachte angeblich weiße
menschen zum schweigen ich wurde nun das
problem also habe ich den blog beitrag
geschrieben
ich sagte ich kann mich nicht mit leuten
über die nassen des problems unterhalten
wenn sie nicht einmal erkennen dass das
problem existiert eigentlich hatte sich
dem gespräch am zogen sondern eigentlich
dort nicht gemacht dass um über diese
themen zu sprechen menschen ein gewisses
bewusstsein entwickeln müssen also
anfangen müssen in dem fall die
architektur von rassismus zu erkennen
und zu erkennen wie rassismus
menschen nennt menschlich dass er
stattfindet und wenn das problem ich
einmal erkannt wird und gesehen wird
dann kann man sich den mund fusselig
reden
es gibt ein sehr schönes zitat von der
afro amerikanischen schriftstellerin
toni morrison gesagt du fängst race
trucks sind natürlich englischsprachig
das ist aber aber was sie damit zeigt
ist dass menschen die permanent über
rassismus sprechen müssen es kann aber
auch auf andere diskriminierungs
mechanismen übertragen die permanent
erklären müssen warum etwas sexistisches
warum etwas antisemitisch ist dieser
menschen wir permanent davon abgehalten
zu allen anderen themen die sie in ihrer
menschseins bildung verändern könnten
die in ihrer natur vielleicht sind in
ihren interessen in ihrem charakter
entsprechen würden abgehalten werden
sondern primär und immer wieder die
funktion haben den menschen die nicht
gewillt sind ihre augen aufzumachen sich
umzuschauen die architektur wahrzunehmen
genau das probieren jahre lang zu tun
das macht man ein paar jahre lang aber
es kann man kein leben lang machen
ich sehe das genauso ist eigentlich eine
art wutausbruch kein gesprächsabbruch
sondern das gefühl man ist in einem
rollen gefängnis in einem klischee
gefängnis und man möchte daraus und das
gespräch ist in einer weise auf gleisen
gebaut die schlicht und einfach ins
nichts oder in die überanstrengung in
die erschöpfung in die verstärkung der
schmerzen von denen hier die rede ist
führen und das interessante ist dann zu
fragen wie kommt man auf ein anderes
gleis und das andere gleis ist
tatsächlich da sind wir wieder beim
begriff unter denen wir am anfang
gesprochen haben ist vielfalt ist
komplexität ist ambivalent jeder mensch
ist interessant wenn man ihn nicht
fixiert auf eine einzelne eigenschaft
und dass das utopische moment des
dialogs ist ja dass wir uns in unserer
vielschichtigkeit kennenlernen können
und dass wir uns gewissermaßen in dieser
vielschichtigkeit des anderen der seine
faszination hat seine hobbys seine
lieben
und seine wutausbrüche hat dass wir uns
in der komplexität und vielfalt
gewissermaßen gemeinsam beheimaten
können da entsteht dass ich sehe das wie
als ob das so zu sagen so ein
vielfarbiges system ist die komplexität
und auf einmal ein gemeinsames netz von
bezügen entsteht wenn ich den anderen
nur als flüchtlinge oder frustrierten
ostdeutschen der mit seiner
lebensleistung nicht klarkommt betrachte
dann sehe ich nicht in dem moment in dem
ich ihn sehe was er liebt entsteht eine
gemeinsame verbindung in dem moment in
dem ich erkenne wie er mit seinem kind
umgeht oder sich für einen kranken
engagiert sehe ich ihn anders kann ich
ihn nicht mehr hassen in gewissem sinne
ich glaube ihnen das ja alles und so
kinder eigentlich total
trotzdem ist es nicht ein bisschen zu
kuschelig also glaube ich damit zu jung
ich werde mir müssen thomas bauer noch
noch einbringen den sie ja auch zitieren
thomas bauer ein islamwissenschaftler
der vor glaube ich eineinhalb jahren
diese sehr interessante buch geschrieben
habe die vereinigung der welt und diese
ambiguität intoleranz geprägt hat also
wir sind eine intoleranz der
gesellschaft geworden
bezüglich ambiguität bezüglich
vielschichtigkeit vieldeutigkeit wir
wollen gerne wissen eben wie sie es
schon gesagt haben die frau der mann das
kind übrigens auch das tier und der
mensch das ja auch so eine grenze aber
eben auch die türkin die muslimin der
christ und so weiter nun gibt es aber
auch manchmal ja das gefühl ich kann
doch gar nicht durch die welt gehen wenn
ich nicht kategorie l denke ich muss
doch ein stück weit auch sortieren also
sonst wird der tag ja auch wahnsinnig
anstrengend das gestehen sie in ihrem
buch auch zu es ist manchmal notwendig
in kategorien zu denken
ja und der anspruch ist dass man diesen
absolut heizkörper nicht ran koppelt
nämlich dass man ein bewusstsein dafür
lebt dass diese kategorien nur letztlich
werkzeuge sind um uns dadurch die welt
zu navigieren aber dass sie uns nicht
die welt abschließend erklären dass
weder ein mensch und abschließend
erklärt werden kann durch eine benennung
einer kategorie
noch kann die große weite welt von der
wir ja unheimlich wen ich erst begriffen
haben mit unseren werkzeugen mit unseren
menschlichen werkzeugen dass man diese
neugier
erhält und gleichzeitig einander den
raum zugesteht dass man mal so mal so
sein kann also dinge also eine frage die
ich immer wieder stelle menschen ist
könnten sie über sich abschließend sagen
wer sie sind in drei sätzen in einem
gespräch innerhalb eines tages die
allermeisten menschen könnten das nicht
wird sagen kein mensch kann das weil wir
alle in unserem entscheidungsprozesse
nicht fertig und da geht ein leben lang
weiter
und wenn wir aber uns festnageln müssten
dann würden wir eine enge verspüren aber
genau das tun wir mit anderen menschen
und ich glaube dass wir menschen
eigentlich in der lage sind mit dieser
komplexität umzugehen und der ambiguität
umzugehen denn wir sind ja in einer
gewissen ausnahmesituationen ländern wie
deutschland ich weiß in der schweiz gibt
es unterschiedliche sprachen
beispielsweise die gesprochen werden
deshalb müsste man schauen wie die
ambiguität toleranz ihr ist aber
eigentlich sehr ungewöhnlich wenn ein
mensch nur eine einzige sprache spricht
und glaubt diese eine sprache würde die
gesamte welt ihm erklären können denn
jede sprache deckt nur das ab was
diejenigen menschen die in einer sprache
macht und herrschaft besitzen erfahren
haben und alles was jenseits dessen ist
ist eigentlich noch nicht ergründet und
wenn man diesem bewusstsein lebt dann
geht man anders mit der welt rum und das
ist ja auch ein gebiet mit dem sie sich
ganz speziell gut auskennen was auch ein
bisschen der rote faden ist ihres buches
sprache und sein weil sie selber
natürlich 34 sprachen eigentlich perfekt
beherrschen oder 33 türkisch englisch
und deutsch sind ihre sprachen und sie
sagen auch und zeigen das sehr schön in
diesem buch wie in jeder sprache eine
andere welt eigentlich so ein bisschen
im vordergrund ist andere gefühle
vielleicht auch andere gerüche andere
binder andere heiraten und das
vielleicht noch ein bisschen deutlicher
zu machen eine schöne geschichte sie
sitzen am meer mit ihrer tanze in der
türkei und ihre tante deutet aufs meer
und sagt guck mal da ist sie verwendet
ein wort ja camus und sie sehen nichts
und ihre eltern erläutern ihnen ja camus
und plötzlich sehen sie es weil ihre
eltern in deren jakobus ist die
spiegelung des mondes auf dem wasser und
das finde ich ein so schönes spielen
weil es uns zeigt manchmal sehen wir
dinge erst wenn dir den begriff dafür
haben
das ist
eigentlich doch sehr eindrücklich oder
absolut ja ja wir brauchen ein wort oder
ein begriff um eine vorstellungswelt
abzurufen und in gewissem sinne ist
sprache ein wunderbares instrument der
vervielfältigung aber auch einen
wahrnehmungs gitter dass einzelne
weltansichten transportiert privilegiert
hervorhebt und andere fast unsichtbar
machen kann und dann müsste man doch
diese sprachbilder die helfen befördern
mehr davon machen und diejenigen die
einen engen irgendwie wieder los werden
auf ein sehr gutes beispiel was ja auch
bringt ein tragisches beispiel ist von
der philosophin miranda afrika die das
buch geschrieben habt epiz temic in just
is also epidemische ungerechtigkeit und
sie nennt das den begriff der sexuellen
belästigung genau und man hat gesehen
vom moment an muss diesen begriff gab
hat natürlich nicht die sexuelle
belästigung zugenommen die gab es ja
vorher schon aber es gab sehr viel mehr
meldungen es gab sehr viel mehr
gespräche darüber weil man einen begriff
dafür gefunden hat das interessante war
an diesem beispiel zweierlei erstens
weil zuvor dieses wort nicht weit
verbreitet war konnte dann
beispielsweise eine frau die am
arbeitsplatz von ihrem chef
beispielsweise sexuelle belästigung
erfahren hat das problem nicht veräußern
weil entweder das waren flott und damit
okay oder aber es muss eine
vergewaltigung stattfinden damit ein
problembewusstsein geherrscht hat dass
die folge war erstens dass sie sich
schlechter schützen könnte weil sie das
nicht veräußern konnte in der form wie
sie ist nun mit dem wort kam
und zweitens der chef war sich keiner
schuld bewusst das heißt das
problembewusstsein und das nicht dass
nicht existieren diese linguistische
lücke hat ihn sozusagen davor befreit
verantwortung für sein handeln zu
übernehmen
und was ich unheimlich spannend finde an
der betrachtung dieser beispiele ist wie
uns deutlich wird dass unsere
sprachliche architektur uns ermöglicht
die große weite welt da draußen
irgendwie zu begreifen aber zugleich
auch mauern baut pro bestimmten
erfahrungen die nur menschen machen die
in einer sprache vielleicht
unterrepräsentiert sind oder in dem fall
60er jahre
frauen nicht den gleichen zugang zu
schriften zum schreiben für zu
öffentlichkeit hatten die männer das
hatten
und das heißt und das ist für mich auch
die lösung gewesen tatsächlich da an ein
zitat was mich sehr bewegt hat war auch
ein afroamerikanischer schrift oder
james baldwin der sich mit der sprache
beschäftigt hat und sich gefragt warum
kann diese sprache mein dasein nicht
tragen und hat gesagt ja das kann die
schulter sprache sein
aber vielleicht ist es auch meine schuld
weil es ist meine verantwortung meiner
erfahrung in diese sprache zu tragen und
ich glaube wenn man über lösungen
nachdenkt wie können wir eine
sprachliche architektur schaffen die
menschen in ihrem facettenreichtum
empfangen kann dann wenn man im bild
gleiche tektur bleibt müssen wir diese
architektur erweitern türen einbauen
neue gebäude anhängt wörter schaffen für
situationen zu den für dieses feuer
keine worte ganz zwei drei spielen noch
die ganz neu und frisch sind 1 training
zum beispiel ist ein aus dem wieder
englischen rahmen ein wort das
beschreibt wenn männer frauen eine
diesmal wurden sie eine größere
expertise besitzt als eher oder men's
bretting das heißt wenn männer in u und
s bahn besonders breitbeinig sitzt man
sehr viel raum einnehmen
das sind alles wörter die eine erfahrung
aus nicht männlicher perspektive
beschreiben und das aufkommen dieser
wörter führt eigentlich dazu dass unsere
sprachliche architektur ausgeweitet wird
und dass wir plötzlich dinge sehen die
wir vorher so nicht gesehen haben weil
sie alle unter diesen begriff fallen
überlegen sie wollen ja nicht dass wir
weiter so zu sagen kuscheln und diese
natürlich beschäftige gewalt etwas
dagegen sagen nein ich kann nichts
dagegen sagen aber ich kann einen
gedanken an führen aus meiner sicht ist
die wunderbare und zum teil auch
beängstigende seite der aktuell
laufenden kommunikationsrevolution dass
wir immer mehr unterschiede sofort und
ganz unmittelbar sehen
das heißt wir können immer neue nuancen
einführen und auch ungerechtigkeiten
immer präzise bestimmen was macht man
mit menschen die sagen das ist mir alles
zu viel ich fühle mich nicht mehr
zurecht finde mich nicht mehr zurück ich
fühle mich beengt durch die neuen
regularien
ich verstehe die nicht mehr gar nicht
mehr frei sprechen ja das gut dass das
kann man ja nachgewiesenermaßen also
niemand holt einen ab wenn man jetzt
hier irgendwas sagt das ist ja an sich
selbst wieder legen da terror vorwurf
aber aber wie und das ist die frage die
mich moment beschäftigt ich weiß nicht
ob sie an die kuschelig genug ist
übersetzt man die massivität der
unterschiedlichkeit die auf einmal
sichtbar wird in eine tatsächlich
lebbare sprach und
kommunikationsstrategie wir haben im
akademischen milieu natürlich unendlich
viel zeit wir können uns immer neue
begriffs unterscheidung überlegen oder
auch neue sprach vorgaben so berechtigt
die im einzelnen sein mögen aber wie
kann ein solcher ansatz und es ist
wirklich eine ganz ernste frage in die
breite der gesellschaft wirken
gewissermaßen sichtbar werden das ist
hier um eine sehr reale schmerzens
erfahrung geht sichtbar werden dass es
hier nicht darum geht irgendjemand zu
unterdrücken oder eine gruppe nach vorne
zu spielen und einen neuen machtkampf
unter dem deckmantel des antirassismus
anzuzetteln
das sind ja alles so vorwürfe die
regierung also wie reagiert man darauf
da habe ich keine lösung ist eine ganz
ernste frage wie macht man die massiert
hat der unterschiede die auf einmal
sichtbar werden auf eine attraktive
weise erfahrbar und nicht als eine neue
belastung
erstens das also wie machen geht es dass
das attraktiv gesehen wird aber das
zweite was mich auch auf beschäftigt ist
ziemlich manchmal blind dafür
verletzende pauschalisierungen zu
erkennen wenn ihr selber nicht darunter
fallen also gerade alle die begriffe die
sie genannt haben man's planning der
alte weiße mann man's trading alle diese
geschichten merke ich oft dass sich
natürlich das klima einfach auch gedreht
hat dh es ist plötzlich ich sage es
jetzt trotzdem mal so relativ salonfähig
geworden bösartige pauschalisierung
vorwürfe in den raum zu stellen die
männer attackieren und die frauen zum
teil auch sehr genussvoll benutzen
inklusive zuweilen mir selbst
selbstanzeige weil man ich mich denkt
man war selber so lange in der
unterdrückten situation aber das schafft
natürlich keine gute gesprächssituation
nein es geht auch nicht darum so zu tun
als müsste man jetzt alles heimzahlen
und alle müssen jetzt in diese
diskussion gefängnis sondern rollen
gedrängt werden und ist sollen die mal
leiden weil ich hab so viele
jahrhunderte und jahrtausende nicht
leiden mussten sondern es geht vielmehr
darum und ich glaube da kann man auch
menschen abholen das war das was ich im
buch zumindest probiert habe nicht
direkt mit dem politischen zu beginnen
sondern einfach mich zu den menschen zu
setzen und anzufangen mich umzuschauen
entsprachen zu gehen wo menschen keine
zahlen nutzen in sprachen zu gehen wo
sind menschen nicht mit rechts und links
orientieren sondern mit himmelsrichtung
orientieren entsprachen zu gehen wo
menschen kann in zukunft und
vergangenheitsform nutzen und zu zeigen
wie an dass diese menschen die welt
wahrnehmen aufgrund der sprache die sie
sprechen und dann durch diese reihe sind
auch die eigene sprache zurückzuschauen
zu sagen wollen wir so leben ist dass
unser ideal und nicht mit
schuldzuweisungen und du bist schuld und
du hast es aufrecht erhalten und mit
diesem fingerzeig sondern dass man
gemeinsamen schulterschluss schaut ist
das wirklich unser ideal um vielleicht
vorgelagert noch einfach nur zu erkennen
sprache und welt also sprache schafft
welt ich habe im vorfeld die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer gefragt ob
es schweizer deutsche wörter gibt von
denen sie denken die gibt's nicht auf
hochdeutsch und die eine welt schaffen
von denen sie den anderen kommen die
können sie nicht wieder gehen auf
hochdeutsch
hier ist eine liste das sind wörter die
genannt wurden sind möglich ohne
größeren uster technologie günter krings
receiver lila nicht verheben lauter
begriffe die mir vertraut sind ich
verstehe sofort was die zuschauen
zuschauerinnen gemeint haben mit diesen
begriffen und warum sie wirklich denken
es ist schwierig man zu erklären was man
tut wenn man immer grün schreibt ja das
ist so was ein bisschen
ein bisschen was versorgen ein bisschen
bist nein nein nicht kuscheln das ist
mir so für sich grimm schule ein
bisschen ein bisschen für sich sein und
bisschen disco und bist du das tun ohne
wirklichen zweck zum beispiel und das
finde ich interessant ansprache und das
finde ich interessant annehmen auch sie
sagen dass man doch plötzlich feststellt
das hat ja auch seine zärtlichkeit dass
sprache welten schaffen kann und wenn
man einander teilhaben lässt an dieser
sprache dann merkt man plötzlich was man
alles entdecken kann wenn man sich
einlässt auf das gespräch auf das reden
des anderen
wenn man es wenn man es etwas pathetisch
unterbrechen wollen würde was ich nicht
tun aber jetzt mal für die sensitive
richter tätig sein
es ist ein mangel an demut es wenn ein
mensch glaubt seine perspektive würde
sei die einzig richtige dann ist das ein
mangel an demut wenn ein mensch glaubt
wie die lodges beschreibt in ihrem buch
wenn menschen nicht einsehen wollen dass
rassismus gibt dann ist es ein mangel an
demut weil sie die perspektive an
anderen personen nicht anerkennen wollen
weil sie ihre eigene begrenztheit sich
nicht zugestehen wollen wenn man glaubt
man könnte und das beschreibt thomas
bach in seinem buch was was der
kolonialisierung und überhaupt diese
schreibt von einem universalisierung
cercas also dem ehrgeiz und eine
erkenntnis eine wahrheit die man für
sich entdeckt hat zu universalisierung
und sie zu allgemeingültigen wahrheit zu
erklären
und dieses unter vermessen der welt
dieses fremde länder gehen diese
menschen zu sklaven zu machen ihre nasen
zu messen die breite die länge den
abstand zwischen den augen
die sagt dieser irrglaube man keine
menschen messen und abschließend
verstehen universelle aussagen über
menschen treffen das ist ein alles um
ein eklatanter mangel an demut ist das
die lösung wir haben einen mangel an
demut dass wir müssen demut trainieren
kann wieder besser sprechen miteinander
sprechen weil das zeigt das ist
natürlich eine haltung frage ist mit
welcher haltung nähert man sich der welt
würde man sie sich untertan machen
geht es vor allem um macht um die
befriedigung der eigenen gier oder ist
man bereit den anderen tatsächlich
gewissermaßen als legitimen anderen zu
sehen
das ist vielleicht noch eine noch
unterschätzte kommunikations tugend bei
all dem was wir besprochen haben ist das
zuhören also das zuhören auf eine
bestimmte art und weise meistens hören
wir ja so dass wir sagen stimmt dass
nach meiner auffassung was der andere
sagt das zuhören ist eine art harmonie
erlebnis test wenn der andere genau das
sagt was wir auch gut finden sagen wir
gutermann gute frau prima und das ist
das was erleben in seiner kommunikativen
gestalt aber wir könnten ja auch auf
eine andere weise zu hören die sagt in
welcher welt ist das ist der andere sagt
sinnvoll in welche welt passt es hinein
und dann ist man gewissermaßen in dieser
welt des anderen und der anderer wird
ein legitimer anderer insofern glaube
ich schon es geht um diese haltung
fragen und sprache ist in diesem sinne
auch ein werkzeug das uns nicht völlig
gefangen nimmt sonst könnten wir ja
nichts tun sondern dass uns etwas
eröffnet und trotzdem das wäre der
letzte sitzung und trotzdem müssen wir
heute mehr denn je und das sage ich als
jemand der sein ganzes die ersten zehn
jahre seines akademischen lebens damit
verbracht hat konstruktivismus bücher zu
schreiben bücher über wahrheit und gegen
wahrheit und die gewissheit der
ungewissheit und wahrheit ist die
erfindung eines blieben also ich habe
mich völlig voller euphorie auf diese
sozusagen wahrheit' zweifel idee
gestürzt und trotzdem müssen wir heute
um das was wir hemdsärmlig wie auch
immer wahrheit neuerungen neu streichen
das war ja auch glaube ich die große
erkenntnis in dieser ganzen debatte um
die fake news dass der konstruktivismus
die ganze poststrukturalismus auch die
idee dass wahrheit immer konstruiert ist
fast übertrieben wurde und das und
plötzlich gemerkt hat moment mal es gibt
auch einfach blauen kollegen und da muss
man muss man auch wiederum lernen wenig
dem defizit wahrscheinlich rote linien
absolut und es gibt da draußen einen ein
kolter entfesselten pseudo skepsis also
ich würde schon sagen es skepsis denn
der ernst zu nehmendes
skeptiker hat er genau das was sie
beschreiben er ist demütig auch
gegenüber der eigenen position company
demütig ging rein über die eigenen
position man hat ihn auch nie mit einem
einer schrift von jean botti jahr
herumlaufen sehen oder von foucault
gewissermaßen den wahrheitsbeweis muss
den er heute propagiert kennenzulernen
nein dieser wahrheit zweifel ist ein
brutales instrument der durchsetzung von
macht war falsch ist es was die andere
seite sagt war es das was ich sage also
der der begriff der demo ist ungeheuer
hilfreich um diesen entfesselte diese
entfesselte form der pseudo skepsis tief
im moment im öffentlichen raum auch bei
der klimawandel leugnen industrie
erleben um den irgendwie und
entscheidungsfähig zu machen und
trotzdem brauchen wir so etwas wie
tatsachen wahrheiten und den strahlen
darüber hier haben wir haben angefangen
mit der frage was ist ein gutes gespräch
wir sind bei der demut gelernt wird
vielleicht ist das tatsächlich einer der
schlüssel zumindest empathiefähigkeit
demut die einsicht dass die wahrheit zu
zweit beginnt ich gedanke nicht ganz
ganz herzlich für dieses gespräch frau
gemisch herzen danke dass sie hier waren
danke danke schön ja das war unser
gespräch zum schluss jetzt noch mal ein
monolog respektive die programmhinweise
nächste woche spricht ich boss hat mit
der islamwissenschaftlerin katajun
amirpur über die geschichte des iran und
seine rolle in der gegenwärtigen welt
politik gerne mache ich auch ein
bisschen werbung für ein musikalisches
gespräch erleben sie gleich im anschluss
das gemeinsame konzert von ann sophie
mutter und herbert von karajan in einer
sternstunde musik ihnen allen eine gute
woche
bleiben sie im gespräch bis bald
[Musik]